more people have access
to tobacco and i'm not i'm not
advocating that we
make it an illegal drug i think that
would was a heart would be a horrible
mistake although there is a very
credible push
to to mandate the reduction of nicotine
in cigarettes which i have most
scientists that study it are for it
i think there's some real dangers there
because i see that in the broader
history of drug use it's like when has
drug prohibition
worked broadly speaking and and it's
it's uh to me that would that that path
would only make sense
in very good conjunction with
e-cigarettes which once they're fully
regulated
can be a safer not safe but much safer
alternative and if we don't if we tax
the hell out of e-cigarettes
and ban every attractive feature like
like flavors and everything
then that's gonna push people to a black
market if they can't get the real thing
from real sick like some people would
just quit straight out
but i think with the regulators and what
a lot of scientists that study tobacco
like myself it's a big part still what i
study
um they're not used to thinking about
the
like tobacco really as a drug largely
speaking in terms of
you know for example the history of
prohibition and i think of like we
already know there's an illicit market a
black market for
tobacco to get around um you know taxes
i mean and for selling even loose
cigarettes that's what initially caused
in staten island the police to approach
uh was it
eric garland who was selling loose
cigarettes and he got choked out
i mean the thing that caused that police
contact was he was selling well
i think report it to sell individual
cigarettes for like you know you could
sell them for court it happens in
baltimore and it's like that's
technically illegal
it's but you know are you not going to
have
massive boats of you know supplies
coming over from china and elsewhere of
real deal cigarettes if you ban
you know the sale nicotine like it's
obviously going to happen
and you have to weigh that against you
know you're going to create a black
market
one size or another and your intuition
that really hasn't worked throughout the
history when we've tried it
right but i see a potential path forward
but only if it's well
if it's not in conjunction with
e-cigarettes if there's a clear
alternative that's a positive
alternative that
it kind of stares the population
that right ditto is an alternative yeah
the difference here the the unique thing
that could be taken advantage of here is
nicotine is by and large not what causes
the harm
it's the the aromatic hydrocarbons it's
the
the carcinogens in in in tobacco it's
burning tobacco smoke it's not the
nicotine
so um that it's not like alcohol
prohibition where
like you know you couldn't create the
adults the the near beer is not going to
have the alcohol
and so people like here you do have the
possibility of giving a an
another medium the ability to deliver
the drug
which still aren't to a lot of people
isn't preferred to the tobacco but
nonetheless
again if you over regulate those and
make them less attractive like if you
aren't thoughtful about the nicotine
limits and thoughtful about whether
you're allowing flavors and everything
and if you
over tax them you're actually decreasing
the ability to compete with the more
dangerous
products so i feel that like there is a
potential path forward but i don't have
a lot of confidence that that's going to
be done in a
thoughtful analytical way and i'm afraid
that it could
decrease the increase of black market
cause all of the
harms like every other drug we're moving
away from the heavy from
the prohibition model slowly but the big
barge ship is like
making a very slow turn and like okay we
really had to step back and question
if we went with nicotine tobacco are we
moving into that direction like yeah the
picture
it doesn't quite make sense
you